Scandal for labor is with us this
morning Hi how are you good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program um
quick thought on Boris Johnson before we
move on to other stuff
I think this week we're just going to
see what we've always seen with Boris
Johnson which is a man who's
more concerned about himself than all
the people who couldn't get to say
goodbye to their loved ones during covid
and will blame anybody else anyone but
himself for his downfall you know it was
uh it wasn't just about the parties he
attended he backed Owen Paterson you
know who'd uh was lobbying on behalf of
companies who paid in me back Chris
pincher when they were all of those
allegations about sexual misconduct and
I think the problem for the
conservatives in Rishi sunak is when
most people are desperately worried
about how on Earth they're going to pay
their bills they see them talking about
themselves more concerned about the
future of the conservative party than
the future of the country and that is
the real problem facing the
conservatives talk to me um about your
remit Shadow Minister for Health and
Social care of course um what more could
have been in the budget as far as you're
concerned well the main thing actually
for me was proper action to get the
economy growing again because it's only
if we've got a growing economy that
we'll have the money that we desperately
need to put into our Vital public
services and after everything that
Jeremy Hunt announced we've seen growth
downgraded uh in in years three four and
five uh going forward we've got the
biggest hit to living standards since
records began and most people are going
to be asking themselves
am I better off uh uh under the the
conservative government
consultant or a senior doctor well you
are if you're a very wealthy person who
has a million pounds in their in their
pension pot that's the only permanent
tax cut we've seen is for people uh the
top one percenter people in terms of
Labor wants that to happen didn't they
well we called for a specific program on
doctors that's what West streeting was
been calling for in its great irony K
that the conservatives were attacking
Wes saying it was an unaffordable scheme
now they're doing it for everybody we
need to take action on the doctors
because we've got such a shortage of
doctors in the NHS
as you know but just for the benefit of
our viewers as you know the treasury
looked at that and it was just too
complicated to do that in a short period
of time I don't believe that because we
already have a bespoke scheme for judges
and look let's talk two years to put in
place but let's look at what what's the
real issue here yeah we're trying to
make sure that the over 50s can go to
work
and the biggest reason why people the
over 50s are economically inactive while
there's been such a big increase is
they've got physical and mental health
problems and because they have caring
responsibilities for elderly and
disabled relatives it's not about this
pension issue so they're not solving
that problem they're not solving the
doctor's issue but they are giving that
big tax cut to me and that's what women
the doctors the senior doctors who have
retired because of the pension issue
they are solving that by saying that you
can you can save as much as you wanted
to well let's see if they if they
actually do that we need a big
transformation we have we need a bit no
we want a bespoke scheme but it was on
two years to be replaced well this well
it probably does under this government
because they take so long to do
everything we think we can move on that
much more quickly we also have a plan
for the biggest ever expansion of the
NHS Workforce in its history but we do
not support a permanent tax cut for the
richest one percent in terms of their
pension pot that's not the right
priority when so many people are
struggling with the cost of living talk
to me about Rwanda if you would please
um I don't know if you I'm sure you did
the Home Secretary at the weekend
talking about the newly constructed
homes for migrants she's hopeful that
the first uh of the those that she wants
to send there will be going in June
um she said these houses are really
beautiful high quality welcoming and I
quite like your interior design I need
some advice myself
think it speaks for itself okay I mean
I'm not interested in a PR opportunity
photos I'm interested in action action
that stops so many people coming over on
these boats I want to see proper action
to tackle the criminal gangs I want to
see a speeded up Asylum Pro process I
want to make sure that action is taken
in the countries where the problems are
created in the first place and people
are you know very concerned about these
issues but they want a proper plan not a
photo opportunity but I'm afraid that's
all we've learned to expect from from
this Home Secretary it's good to see you
as always Liz thanks very much Andy for
joining us thank you